derniers préparatifs de la mercury la
scène qui accueillera vendredi le before
mercury est en train d'être installée au
bourg des anses d'arlet sur la place des
fêtes
en face de la mairie via ce soir il est
interdit de stationner au centre-ville
des déviations seront mises en place le
centre bourg sera saturé depuis l'aller
sur l'allée félix et bruit et aura des
agents de sécurité avec un barriérage
filtrant faut permettre aux manifestants
de rentrer tous ceux qui ont leur place
bras c'est en tout cas une déviation
sera mise en place à l'entrée de la cité
bonne brise jusqu'à la rue de la
batterie siva les hakkas cas le
président de l'association des
secouristes de la martinique qui est le
référent sécurité discours sur la
mercury cinq mille personnes sont
attendues
l'organisation de la sécurité à terre
sera rigoureuse un dispositif est mis en
place avec plus d'une centaine d'agents
de sécurité plus d'une trentaine de
gendarmes qui vont évoluer la police
municipale et la prod de façon à
organiser l'accès sur la plage accéder à
la plage qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça
veut dire tout simplement que vous
hommes
vous n'avez pas le droit de vous
présenter avec un sac le sac qui sera
refusé
obligatoirement pour pouvoir y accéder
sur cette plage il va falloir passer
sous un portique de contrôle et ensuite
à la palpation en mer également la
sécurité d'une part essentielle du
dispositif entre 450 et 600 bateaux sont
attendus sur le blanc d'où nous aurons
sur l'eau la douane nous aurons sur
l'eau les affaires maritimes nous aurons
sur l'eau la gendarmerie maritime qui
vont venir renforcer le dispositif de
contrôle étatique
on ne peut pas se permettre de se
balader sur la zone qui nous est
attribué vous rentrez vous êtes
contrôlés et vous êtes un marais 1.2
bien précis samedi tout le quartier de
la grande anse sera zone piétonne
environ deux cent mille euros ont été
investis pour l'ensemble de la sécurité